today there's four billion people on
social media putting pushing upwards of
200 billion messages into the world
every day it's super competitive the
biggest thing that controls reach and
distribution of content is the
algorithms the algorithms only really
care about one thing and that's user
retention the longer people spend on
these platforms the more ads they can
serve the more profit that they generate
so when we look at content in extending
your virality you have to make it
interesting to the general population
even if they may not care about your
subject they may not have thought about
your subject you still have to play to
them to get that maximum reach and
distribution so we call it the
generalist approach but you can find
plenty of examples especially on YouTube
as you know Graham Stefan teaching
Finance to Millennials like typically
Finance is not a sexy subject so what
does he do how I bought a Tesla for 78
dollars anybody can consume that content
and gain value and entertainment out of
it but still he's playing to the core of
his brand and reaching those people
welcome to the think media show my name
is Heather Torres the host of this show
where we want to help you grow your
influence on YouTube and then turn that
influence into a high income and a high
impact online business and if you're
brand new and this is your first episode
we want to welcome you to what we're
doing here at think media we're creating
a movement of content creators and we're
so grateful that you are here and if
you're one of our returning think media
fan members thanks for tuning in every
single week it's been exploding and
we're just so grateful that all that
we're putting out there to you is
valuable and helpful for your journey
now every single Tuesday we release a
brand new episode here on the YouTube
channel and on the audio podcast but if
you're not yet seeing or hearing on
either one of those platforms we are
putting out exclusive content just for
YouTube and just for the audio so make
sure that you are investing in both of
those so that you can be getting all of
the value we have for you here at think
media and today is really special
because we're talking all about viral
video I know I want to learn how to go
viral just like you do so we brought the
experts to the think media podcast we
are going to be talking about how to
learn the essentials of a viral video
the tips for paid traffic and organic
traffic on social media and why the
traditional approach to social media
marketing doesn't work anymore so you
need this episode if you're trying to
figure out how to make the right videos
to get in front of the right people and
get in front of as many people as
possible well today Sean Cannell is
sitting down with expert Brendan Kane
now if you're unfamiliar with Brendan
Kane's work today is going to be a
breakthrough day for you so get your pen
and paper ready or your notes on your
iPhone and let's jump into our featured
content
welcome back to the think media podcast
I'm super fired up because Brendan Kane
is back with us Brendan I'm not sure if
you know but one of our most recommended
books that we recommend to our podcast
community and as a required reading for
our content team is your book hook point
and uh we got to talk about that last
time so of course we're going to link up
that conversation in the show notes but
I'm super fired up to have you back on
the podcast how things been it's been
great a little hectic traveling all over
the world but can't complain can't
complain when you're traveling and
enjoying life and uh man I'm excited
because we're going to talk about really
some of the things that are just not
working anymore on social media a lot of
things that creators influencers
businesses are doing wrong
um and we'll talk about paid traffic
versus organic traffic strategies and I
can't wait to talk about what your
you've called uh engineering viral
virality right and so um with that let's
kind of dive in though and maybe give us
just an overview you of who you are and
how you help people for people that are
just meeting you
yeah I mean first off I've been in
social media since the earliest stages
that I started in 2004 2005. so I've
seen the whole evolution of this some
people kind of look at me or other
social media experts and they're like oh
they've only been doing this for a few
years but myself and my team we've been
in the earliest stages and initially
started in the film industry building
digital divisions for movie studios and
that was a unique experience because we
would invest tens of millions of dollars
into a single piece of content and then
we would need hundreds of millions of
people around the world to know about
this piece of content in a matter of
months we didn't have years we didn't
have decades so that really trained me
up on how to effectively harness the
power of digital traffic and social
media to really scale and that's really
how I got started in this whole Space is
figuring out solutions to that big
problem
and one of the things you did your first
book was actually kind of also based on
a case study of what a million followers
in 30 days yeah so I had spent about so
first off I went from film to paid media
and
helped advise an agency where we were
managing about a hundred million dollars
in spend for like Fortune 100 brands and
I just saw the tremendous inefficiencies
of that process because you would have a
huge brand come to you with a piece of
content that they would spend hundreds
of thousands or millions of dollars to
produce and then they were saying hey we
want to spend millions of dollars
against this piece of content and when I
had asked them well how do you know
that this piece of contents can perform
to the tune of investing all this money
they didn't have any data or analytics
to support that decision they were just
doing it off of a creative hunch and I
thought that there must be a better way
of going about that so I left working on
that company
and started building a set of testing
methodologies to test content at scale
to really understand what works what
content formats what structures
storytelling techniques work so that it
would make sense to invest money and
then that extended to journalists
athletes celebrities reaching out to me
with their primary goals how do we build
an audience so that we can monetize our
presence through brand sponsorships and
Deals and things like that so I spent
about three and a half years testing
content I probably tested over a hundred
thousand variations of content over that
time period and then I could see the
patterns and I knew that I could do it
for anybody starting from scratch
because I would always get the question
well Brenda that's great you've worked
with like an MTV or Taylor Swift but
it's not going to work for the average
person it's not going to work for me but
I knew it could work so I thought well
why not run an experiment to prove it
and I thought why not do it on myself
because I wasn't in television or film I
was behind the scenes that entire time
but why not do it it on myself starting
from scratch starting from zero to prove
this out and that's where the experiment
for the book one million followers came
of where I built a million followers in
30 days
that's wild and so can you unpack
actually some of those best practices
and that maybe can help us that was
Instagram correct I did Facebook first
and then I created another system for
Instagram and hit a million followers on
Instagram too okay and so and would you
say that those principals still work
today yes very much so so let's talk
about a little best practices for uh
Instagram that you discovered
so we have a viral content Engineering
Process and this process works for any
platform Facebook Instagram YouTube Tick
Tock and the reason that this platform
or this process works and works no
matter what change happens is it's
deeply rooted into research so what that
means is most people think about
research is oh I'm just going to look at
my direct competitors and see what
they're doing Without Really analyzing
the results and then they try and
replicate that but what we do oftentimes
when we're working with a brand or a
client we yes we look at their direct
competition but oftentimes the direct
competition is not performing at a high
level so it'll tell you what not to do
which is important as well so what we do
is we extend research to other creators
and different niches whether it's
influencers or Brands and really dissect
what is causing them to go viral and
when we're looking at that we're looking
at nuances so we have over 50 different
performance in indicators that we're
looking at so this goes down to like
pacing tonality number of edits first
three seconds thumbnail headline caption
all of these variables and what we do is
we have a research process that's called
gold silver bronze so we can take any
account or any format and we break it
down into these three things gold silver
bronze so gold is the highest reformers
so that's like the viral one so if we're
looking at an Instagram account and
their gold maybe is like five to ten
million views per video and then we look
at their silver which is their Baseline
their average which may be like a
million or under and then bronze which
is their underperformers which is like a
hundred thousand or less and for the
average person these numbers may be big
but you can still learn from it so what
we do with that is we study the gold and
we look for these performance drivers we
look at the hypotheses of what we think
is causing this content to go viral and
again it's not about the content it's
about the context
so the Nuance these nuanced details that
I mentioned but then once we come up
with these hypotheses then we have to
check do they show up in the silver and
the bronze because if they show up in
the silver and the bronze we have to
knock it out and start all over again
until we find these performance drivers
that don't show up in the silver and
bronze so that's the core Crux of our
plat or our process and this process is
backed by about 60 billion views and 100
million followers in a billion in
revenue and the reason it's so
successful is we're not going after
brand guidelines we're not going after
creative intuition and just driving into
ideation we're always starting with
research first to determine what's
working today because as you know things
are changing constantly whether it's a
new feature like Instagram reels a new
platform like Tick Tock or the algorithm
changes things of that nature so let me
know if I got it right and I want to
unpack some things for our listeners the
first that's so powerful that she said
is the mistake people make is they only
research their competitors and their
competitors might not be doing very well
or they only look if the other channels
on YouTube the other Instagram accounts
they study they may not be doing very
well and what you suggest is actually go
find the people killing it the most on
the platform extrapolate what you can
learn from them and apply that to your
content and if you're just starting
that's your best case as well because
you don't have any of your own content
to measure so really try to reverse
engineer content best platforms not just
the other real estate agents or the
other people giving social media tips or
the other people that's incredibly
powerful do I have that right absolutely
because most people they may not even
look at their competitors they may just
jump into creative ideation coming up
with ideas and producing them and not
really knowing and the other big
challenge is
like even with like Instagram reels or
Tick Tock they'll give you some free
wins and you can go viral a few times
but if you don't understand yeah why it
went viral then you can't reproduce it
over and over again and that's where you
see
um people build large followings but you
see a huge discrepancy in their
performance as maybe their hit rate is
one out of 20 one out of 30 that go
viral versus our passion and what we
want to do is how do we get that hit
rate to like one out of two one out of
three so there's not this wave and
fluctuation of performance in your
content
beautiful and that again you can start
applying that you're saying research one
of the things you should start with is
research which is actually we have in
our proprietary process for YouTube uh
our first R is reverse engineer our
second one is then research you know
start with the end in mind and then
start actually researching first before
you press record and so if you don't
have content you could study best
practices if you do have content go into
your library and look at your gold your
silver and your bronze and try to
identify the winners and pull principles
out of those is that accurate because
once you've got a data set how many
videos do you think people need to post
they always ask this let's just say
YouTube you have a YouTube channel how
big of a data set 10 videos posted 20 30
would you say you need to actually start
getting some
enough insights of your own content to
start pivoting your strategy well I
think you can start with as little as 10
but the big thing is is what is your
performance to date because if you
haven't broken through then analyzing
your own content is not really going to
help you know if you haven't gotten a
breakthrough video that's had a few
million views
then it's going to be tough because
you're looking at underperforming
content so what we always want to do
when we're doing research and insights
is figuring out how we break through how
do we break through at the highest
levels because that's how you learn is
looking at the top content creators in
the planet so I wouldn't recommend
really diving too deep into your content
until you've had that breakthrough
performance but in addition like as you
know with YouTube you can start looking
at your retention graph you can look at
your click-through rate on thumbnails
and things like that to see where that's
falling off
um to fix the problem like if you have a
high click through rate in your
thumbnail but your retention's not good
or your retention is good but the click
through on your thumbnail is not good
that gives you a clear indication of
where your performance is breaking down
but just be very careful of analyzing
your own content in the beginning
because it may just get you in this
hamster wheel of just doing low
performing content and not looking at
the things that really truly break
through beautiful now one thing I know
that will pique our listeners mind
though is your definition of what
breakthrough is and would you say that
breakthrough is only millions of views
or is there a place where actually a lot
of our clients sometimes are in like
hyper-specific niches and sometimes we
use the term vfm viral for me because if
you're getting 10 000 views or 15
thousand views and you're a loan officer
and that's leading to just an outrageous
amount of inbound leads that's helping
you grow your business you're in
financial services you're in local real
estate one of the uh people in our
community Levi from living in Dallas him
and his partner Travis did something
like 92 million uh in the Top Line real
estate Revenue which translated to you
know 3.2 million in real estate
commissions and they were under 5 000
YouTube subscribers but they just had so
much inbound of people finding their
Channel Finding their content about
specific neighborhoods so yeah frame
that up because you're this viral
specialist but I think that maybe
sometimes listeners might feel a
pressure that if I don't get a million
views
there's not necessarily a viable
business there or I'm not winning where
we've actually seen sometimes smaller
numbers if it's the right viewers can be
all you need to accomplish your end goal
for your business yeah I think that that
that's a great Point uh and kind of when
I talk about breakthrough performance
it's in their research and insights
process so when we're analyzing other
accounts we want to be analyzing
accounts that are doing in the millions
of views now that doesn't mean that that
has to be the goal for yourself but
they're obviously hitting a chord they
understand the nuances of how to tell a
story how to grab attention how to hold
attention so what we're saying is let's
look at the highest reformers in Social
learn what it's
what is causing them to have that level
of virality and then take those
learnings and apply it to our content
and like you said is like one of the
great analogies that I say is let's just
say your video performance on average is
a thousand views of video and of those
thousand people viewing each one of your
videos fifty percent is your core Target
now let's say that we do this research
and we Master the nuances of what's
causing these other creators to go viral
and then we take our video performance
from a thousand views to a hundred
thousand views and obviously as we know
with scale that core percentage of your
target is going to drop let's say it
drops down to twenty percent we just
went from 500 potential customers to 20
000 with each video that we're producing
so the goals are personal to their to
yourself it like you said you don't have
to be in the millions of views to build
a business to build an audience but
we're saying let's study the people at
the highest levels to learn what they're
doing so that we can you know apply it
because it if we're let's just say in
the 10 000 views of video or a hundred
thousand views of video we're just
studying other people that are ten
thousand a hundred thousand you're not
going to figure out really how to break
through and take it to that next level I
love that that's incredible Clarity
let's kind of pivot to get some of your
best practices by going from the
mistakes angle so you get to observe uh
of course brands of businesses our
listeners are individual creators for
the most part many that are in education
Niche and so they're you know again real
estate Fitness some on the entertainment
side and more vlogging but uh as a you
know it could be DIY crafts sewing
parents that maybe are helping other
parents with solve problems Tech
reviewers all kinds of different things
teaching something on YouTube
predominantly
the mistakes people are making that are
just killing viral before it even starts
what are some of the biggest ones that
you see uh people making today yeah we
just covered the re research side which
I think is a huge place that people are
falling flat I mean that's why we've
pivot our entire company only to do
research and insights we don't produce
content or anything all we do is deliver
research and insights to creatives but I
think the other big and I don't know if
I want to call it a mistake it's it's
not understanding the world that we live
in today so when I started in Social I
remember the exact day Myspace released
a press release saying that they reached
a million users and that was a huge
thing you fast forward today there's
four billion people on social media
putting pushing upwards of 200 billion
messages into the world every day it's
super competitive and as you and I know
the biggest thing that controls reach
and distribution of content is the
algorithms and there's a lot of
misunderstanding of the algorithms and
one of them is they suppress your reach
on purpose to get you to pay for reach
that's not the case because nobody would
ever go viral the algorithms only really
care about one thing and that's user
retention the longer people spend on
these platforms the more ads they can
serve the more profit that they generate
so what they're really looking for is
content that they can see to the widest
possible audience and hold that
attention for the widest possible or for
time
so when we look at content in extending
your virality one of the things that you
had mentioned is Niche business owners
so even with a niche business you have
to make it interesting to the general
population even if they may not care
about your subject they may not have
thought about your subject they may not
be your core customer you still have to
play to them to get that maximum reach
and distribution so we call it the
generalist approach we're not saying
ditch kind of the context that you want
to provide to your core audience but how
do we make it interesting to anybody so
most people think oh you can't do that
for a niche thing my my subject matter
is not sexy or interesting but you can
find plenty of examples especially on
YouTube clear tax value it's a YouTube
account with over a million subscribers
they're averaging three to five hundred
thousand views of video they have
several videos over a million views it's
about taxes
as you know Graham Stefan teaching
Finance to Millennials like typically
Finance is not a sexy subject so what
does he do how I bought a Tesla for 78
dollars he's making it interesting to
anybody that wants to view that content
but he's still teaching the fundamentals
that he wants to deliver or a real
estate agent Ryan Serhant over a million
subscribers on YouTube what does he do
he sells property to a very specific
audience people that can afford 10 20 30
50 million dollar properties in New York
but he makes it interesting by saying
hey let me take you on a two of a seven
million dollar closet let me take you on
a tour of a 250 million dollar Ranch
anybody can consume that content and
gain value and entertainment out of it
but still he's playing to the core of
his brand and reaching those people even
if it's a fraction of one percent off a
million views that's extremely
meaningful so I think that generalist
approach to content is where most people
are still operating on the old paradigm
time which worked before when there was
less people on the platforms less
competition but when we look at the fact
that there's four billion content
creators on the planet we really need to
play to what really controls reach and
distribution of virality which is the
algorithms
well I hope that you are enjoying
today's conversation and I wanted to let
you know that if you want to go deeper
with us here at think media one of the
best ways to do that to further your
online education is to take one of our
free on-demand classes you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com where we do a one
hour free deep dive class into what's
working on YouTube right now and how you
can game subscribers and Views and
income from your YouTube channel we have
several different options for you but
the latest video for you to watch is at
thinkmasterclass.com this video is not
available anywhere on YouTube this is
only exclusively for our think media
Community who are ready to go deeper
with us at the end of that class we
share with you an opportunity to become
one of our members inside of this
movement of content creators making a
difference in the world so go to
thinkmasterclass.com right now to get
signed up for your free one hour YouTube
on-demand class now let's get back into
to today's featured content
so number one it's a huge mistake if
you're not doing your research first
number two not understanding the
platforms and operating in the old
Paradigm and not the new paradigm what
are some other old Paradigm mistakes you
see people making well I think frequency
is a big one and I'm not saying
frequency doesn't have its place
frequency can lead to success but only
once you fundamentally understand your
format what works what doesn't work you
know I see a lot of people talking about
you need to be posting every day
multiple times a day but how does that
help you especially when we talked about
the algorithms the algorithms are not
going to reward you because you're
producing more content they're going to
reward you because you're producing
content that grabs and holds attention
for as long as possible
I think also there's still and again I'm
not going to say that this was never a
play but people are so focused on like
hashtags time of day things of that
nature which those things aren't going
to take up poorly constructive piece of
content and automatically going to make
it perform so our core focus is on the
content itself and we're a big proponent
of
um quality over quantity I'd rather see
somebody spend two weeks or a month on a
single video than to burn themselves out
creating a piece of content every day
and not learning from it again there are
content creators that have mastered
their format and can scale with that but
if you're just starting out or you
haven't really broken through I always
recommend taking a step back and really
getting something to perform and then
increase the frequency if you deem that
that's appropriate I mean we know Mr
Beast he's the most subscribed person on
YouTube across all his channels it's
like he'll take months to produce a
single video and even in the beginning
he would take that time to really master
that art of what it takes to create
content that that holds attention and
I'm glad you brought this stuff this is
a huge debate and I know people are like
okay is it quality is it quantity speak
about the timeline to that because
sometimes quantity at first can be like
your first few days of showing up at the
gym though to develop just some basic
fundamentals of form maybe even before
you're ready to dial in quality and to
that point I think Mr Beast had 200
videos out before he even kind of got a
little bit of steam so there was quite a
bit of a quantity before he learned the
nuances that he knows today so people
are looking for like a black or white
answer and I do feel like it is a little
bit gray I like that you're saying
ultimately
quality especially if you study Mr Beast
there's a play there but then there's
others and now a guy I'm watching is one
rental at a time it's a very Niche news
show uh for uh people that want to do
real estate and rentals meet Kevin for a
while who also
um similar to Graham Stefan and Andre he
was doing three videos a day a lot of
financial news not live streams he would
shoot him quick edit them quick jump on
some headlines he was pulling 20 45 65
000. so I feel like and and fighting for
the listener
uh can you give me an answer I mean it's
this this quality quantity tension
um there's a lot of different
distinctions on it yeah yeah and I think
that going back to Mr Beast because he
was recently on Joe Rogan and Joe Rogan
asked him like how did you learn how to
go viral yeah Joe not understand this
said did you watch some tutorials on
YouTube and he's like no there was no
such thing at the time so and I think he
said that he was like in the 60 000 sub
range but he found four other crazy
lunatics that were high school dropouts
and for a thousand days straight they
would jump on Skype for up to 10 hours a
day breaking down every Nuance of
virality putting a thousand thumbnails
and measuring like color and gradients
and things like that and he said after
that exercise of doing it all of the
people in that group
accelerated their growth dramatic they
are all over a million subscribers in a
few months so even him he was in that
process of understanding doing the
research I even have I I recently hired
a young kid that started on YouTube when
he was 10 years old and he was producing
content every day for years and he
didn't have any growth wow but then when
he started doing the research and
understanding it that's when he exploded
and built a Channel with a million
subscribers so again it's like that
research and insights part is is
critically important I do believe to
what you said is
you don't want to like get into analysis
paralysis you do want to create content
the biggest thing is are you learning
with each piece of content that you're
creating because I think so much of the
frequency game is Just produced content
and things will magically happen
but again maybe you have one or two that
work but if you don't understand
then it's like well how do you reproduce
those results and again reels and Tick
Tock because of the way that algorithms
are structured they're giving some free
wins out there to get people you know
addicted to producing content for the
platform but then you see people fall
off a cliff and I remember this so I
started I did the first ever influencer
campaign on YouTube in 2007. so I was in
that insular community of the first ever
YouTubers and it was interesting because
in the beginning it was much easier
because there was no such thing as an
influencer and they were having these
free wins and I'm not saying that their
content wasn't good but they were
growing like crazy and then as more
people got on the platform the algorithm
shifted a little bit there was a huge
crash and a lot of influencers got wiped
out at that point because the ones that
succeeded were like okay we're going to
figure this out we're going to
understand what was a change how do I
hold attention how do I really create
better content and those people survived
the crash and picked back up
wow
um one thing I heard you say in terms of
best practices new paradigm old Paradigm
was you don't really recommend batch
producing why is that
because we see that so so basically our
process is we do research and insights
and we create hypotheses around these
performance drivers and again it's not
about the content it's about the context
and then we create those hypotheses and
then we go into the ideation phase so we
don't create ideas until we've done the
research
so that we have you know data informed
ideas but then we we go into single
production iteration so we produce one
piece of content at a time and the
reason that we do that is when we review
the results we want to understand that
our hypothesis hold true and if the
video underperformed two things happened
it's either we chose the wrong
hypothesis or we didn't execute the
hypothesis correctly and one of the
easiest exercises people could do is in
that research process we we create a
reference we we single down into a
reference that we want to emulate from a
storytelling perspective and after we
produce that piece of content we put the
new piece of content on one side of the
screen and the reference on the other
and we play it side by side and really
have an honest look did we really
replicate the performance drivers that
we set forth versus if we're batch
producing content it gets lost you may
set a hypothesis for 10 pieces of
content but again if you didn't execute
that hypothesis correctly or if you
chose the wrong performance driver in
that hypothesis process
then you just basically spent all this
time and energy on 10 pieces of content
that you could have knocked out with
just doing one so that's why we don't
really suggest doing batch unless you
really have a strong data and analytics
way of analyzing each piece of content
on its own and to be clear and you could
speak directly into our strategy like
right now you and I are on a video
podcast yeah this video podcast comes
out every Tuesday
um there's no reason why we're avoiding
going viral but I have a feeling this
podcast is not going viral it's also
hitting the audio platforms it's for a
very Niche audience so we do want to
grow the podcast clips from it certainly
could do well and we are not only
executing that but we're going to
execute that even more
but in some cases batching might have a
place would you agree or disagree where
if you're doing something like what
we're doing right now but really what
you help people with is engineering
viral that there's maybe some of your
energy that you want to devote towards
these breakout pieces of content and in
that case batching would not be the
proper approach yeah I would even say
like with podcasts like the approach
that I would do is do research on Lex
Friedman do research on H3 do research
on
um Joe Rogan and study those nuances
of those breakthroughs and apply it to
each podcast that you do because there
are very clear patterns they're very
nuanced like you have to really
understand what you're looking for but
there are very clear patterns that you
can take away with each piece of each
podcast or long-form piece of content or
even the clips that you can learn from
to apply to that so I I would say our
process is for any type of content that
you're producing
whether you anticipate it going viral or
not my my kind of philosophy is if
you're going to produce a piece of
content why not maximize the potential
of it and learn with it because I think
another thing that that that you'll see
on all channels is you'll see people
that have like 2 million subscribers but
then they're generating like 10 000
views of video
and that's a shame because they spent
all this time energy and effort
accumulating this audience and the
algorithms aren't seating their contents
of that audience so why not take all the
time and energy that you've put into
accumulate that audience to just get
better at reaching more and more of it
strong
who are some of the top of Mind YouTube
channels specifically that maybe lean
more educational you mentioned some of
them earlier but when you look at
YouTube channels to study uh that our
listeners may want to check out that are
maybe lesser known and people a lot of
times will mention the big names they'll
mention a Mr Beast or in personal
finance a Graham Stefan but what are
some interesting channels that we can
learn some lessons from I think clear
tax value
um listen they're not going super viral
with every video but their Baseline is
really strong their Baseline is three to
five hundred thousand views of video and
that for taxes that's pretty amazing Dr
Mike is a well-known one but he's taken
um medical to that I don't know how well
Ryan Serhant is known in in your circles
but I think he's done an amazing job of
the generalist approach we've done a lot
of work with Mindvalley which is an
education company their performance is
all over the place but they do have some
major breakthroughs in performance
uh I think from a podcast perspective
it's really fascinating to look at Lex
Friedman because he's a disciple of Joe
Rogan and he's kind of mastered some of
those so I think looking at if you're in
the podcasting space looking at kind of
what he's done is pretty interesting
those are ones I can think of off top my
head I may come up with some more
beautiful
um people ask paid versus organic growth
and uh paid versus organic strategies
what are kind of the pros cons and
mistakes when people should be thinking
about both of those Pro approaches to
generate really a business result
okay so there's two parts to that so
let's just talk about organic for
example I would never put paid behind an
organic piece of content that is
underperforming because again paid is
just going to give you reach it's not
going to cause somebody to stop and
watch the content so we have used in the
past uh very successfully is like if you
have a viral piece of content that takes
off there's always going to be a plateau
and that's a time where you can use paid
to push it again to see if the
algorithms pick up on it and that
organic reach pulls off
um paid is a very effective tool from a
direct response standpoint but we want
to separate organic from paid so we see
organic as a tool to earn the right to
make a sale and then paid as a tool to
retarget that organic to make a more
direct response call to action you can
also use uh paid for cold audiences too
effectively if you again know how to
effectively tell stories if you know how
to do their research and insights on
other AD creators and dissect what
they're doing well
so one of the things you're mentioning
is that you want to create generalist
content and at times have that
generalist strategy you reach a large
audience that gives you more people to
retarget have you found it to be
effective
um though is retargeting lower cost in
that case if you've reached a generalist
audience like you said it may not be
your ideal customer and I watched a
training video from you where you
brought we broke down a case study of uh
John Cena being in whatever brand and
having just kind of a wide entertaining
far-reaching viral piece of content
first and then they were able to
retarget can you tell that story and
maybe illuminate a little bit more on
that yeah so my friends uh run a company
called shareability they're one of the
top viral video creators in the planet
for like Fortune 100 brands and they
took this approach of entertaining first
earning the right to sell so they did a
campaign with the wrestler John Cena
where they were in a a a store and they
had a background of John Cena like a
paper background and they had fans
standing in front of it saying why they
love John Cena and then he would jump
out the back and surprise them and get
that shock Factor generated several
hundred million views organically
but what they saw was okay we're not
there it was for quicker Cricket
Wireless and they did have qriket
wireless branding on it but they didn't
make any type of sale in that it was
just entertainment value so then they
did a direct response ad targeting those
people saying hey this is John Cena
thanks so much for watching the video if
you're interested in learning more about
qriket Wireless go to this destination
it was wildly successful so they
reproduced that viral video but the
reverse side so John Cena came in
thinking he was going to do the exact
same thing before but this time it was
the fan surprising him so he was sitting
behind the cameras in a different room
and he didn't know this was happening
but fans came in and started reading
emotional letters about how they've
impacted his life and it brought John
Cena to tears again there's no sale
that's going through that but they
earned that right and then they
retargeted them with ads now like I have
a friend Craig Clemens who's the top
copywriter in the world he created a
company called Golden hippo that they've
sold over two billion dollars worth of
products and they sell it direct off of
cold ads but what they do is they tell
that story in the ad like these ads are
like 30 to 40 minutes long so they're
telling this story through the ads and
building that emotional connection
building that trust and credibility so
there's multiple different ways that you
can go about it there's no one way to go
to to make a sale or to leverage paid
but just I think a big mistake that
people make is they treat their organic
feed as kind of like an ad feed and that
always falls flat yeah so treat your
organic feed as storytelling meet people
edutainment you can't you wanna you need
to entertain storytell connect
emotionally and that's going to
ultimately lead to your best business
results I heard you say
uh really the business is driving social
in a lot of cases when instead social
should be driving the business can you
explain that more
yeah it's
it's Major Brands like apple apple I
don't know what their subscribers it's
tens of millions of subscribers that's
not driven by social that's driven by
their brand equity in the hundreds of
millions of dollars or more that they're
spending on ads and external places
you look at like the rock for example
he's I think he's the most followed
person on Instagram now people think oh
we did that organically no we didn't
like every movie that he's in they spend
150 million dollars to promote he's on
the cover of every magazine he's on
billboards he's on television ads like
those are external forces that are
driving that in I'm not deluding it by
any means but oftentimes we look at
large brands or large celebrities and
we're trying to study how they grew
Their audience and a lot of times it's
external factors that are driving that
growth and not an internal Factor like a
Mr Beast that's purely grown off of
social so it's really understanding the
delineation between those two
I love that so and you'd be better off
uh studying the Homegrown and you had a
case study uh in that training video
between Chanel and best.dress and it was
the fact that these homegrown social
accounts are much more effective in a
lot of situations than these big Brands
who do have huge amounts of followers
but way less engagement because they're
not doing the best practices right yeah
100 and there's examples of like
multi-level marketing and network
marketing is like we're working with one
of the largest companies in the world
because they have 2.5 million brand reps
and those people are the reason for
their success and they're all selling
through social so for us it's like that
homegrown approach is working for them
now how do we amplify it so it's like
again there's other ways to go about it
like network marketing multi-level
marketing they have all these brand reps
that are pushing their product for them
as well
awesome as we land the plane I do want
to get you to give me your
few next few moves that you'd recommend
uh for starting now if you feel like
you're starting from scratch and the
competition is too big but but before we
get there of course I want to recommend
the listeners grab your book hook point
and we'll link everything up in the show
notes but you also have
goviral.hookpoint.com uh what are people
going to find there if people want to
connect with you and work with you yeah
so at goviral.hookpoint.com essentially
is we do the research for you so every
week we're breaking down a new
influencer content creator brand and
we're going in depth into why they're
going viral so we do that gold silver
bronze research for you we give you that
research sheet we also give you a
recording an hour-long recording of us
breaking down and talking to that
research sheet and then we also give an
activation guide that's like a 10 to 13
page PDF that breaks down all the things
that we've learned and key takeaways
that they can apply to their social
strategy amazing so if you're interested
in that you can check all those links
out in show notes whether on YouTube or
of course the audio podcast show notes
as we land the plane if someone's
looking at the giant of the close of
2022 going into 2023 man competition is
Big of course consumption is higher than
ever before the new numbers I heard is
this 2.6 million monthly active users on
YouTube
and there is growth on these platforms
newer mergers Tick Tock is blowing up uh
I've heard Facebook organic has a
Revival happening there and I'm sure
you're always seeing great stuff
happening on Facebook so there is of
course the big opportunity but it could
it be more real that the competition is
there that it's hard to get reach it's
when especially when you're just
starting it could seem like there's a
major uphill battle what would just be
your one two three you know first couple
steps for the person that feels stuck
and is trying to start from scratch and
get like their first a thousand
subscribers on YouTube well I would
assume that most of these people are
using these platforms so when you're
using these platforms for your personal
consumption
take an active approach instead of a
passive approach when you're watching
content trying to understand why did I
choose to click and watch this video
what is it about this video that's
holding my attention uh in addition if
there's videos that you scroll past why
what was not interesting about that so
really just start to try and learn from
the content that you're consuming to
understand what is driving performance
and what is not driving performance and
listen it takes time to get good at
that's why our whole company is based
upon research to do it for people but
just try and become a student of the
game so I think that that's the first
piece of advice and then secondarily is
really whether you're batch producing
content creating a piece of content
individually is are you learning from
each piece of content that you're
performing and if you're just starting
out you may not have videos that are
performing but are you trying to learn
what is causing it not to perform so
like we said earlier look at your thumb
nail click-through rate look at your
retention graph which one is broken you
know is it you're just not getting
enough people in the door and uh or is
it that you're you're getting people in
the door but they're not staying for a
long period of time so again just be
um
conscious of the content that you're
producing and try and analyze the
results
and then the final thing is it's just a
mindset thing it's like you've said this
on several videos but are you in this
for the long haul this isn't a magic
pill this takes a lot of time energy and
effort to work and if you put that time
and energy in and you learn what causes
content to succeed what content goes
viral and what what detracts from that
virality you will ultimately hit it
because that's where most people fail is
a they're not doing the research and
they're not understanding it but B they
get creative creative burnout and then
they just stop
strong one more question books that have
influenced you the most in regards to
building a business marketing I don't
know how many social media books are out
there of course people should read yours
but maybe it's even something that's a
little more obscure that you've
extrapolated principles to uh for
winning and at 2022-2023 world even from
older school what are some of your
favorites
I always say my favorite book of all
time is how to win friends and influence
people I mean it's first off it's just
amazingly written and I think you learn
a lot about human psychology
um and your kind of preconceived notions
about how you're representing yourself
versus how people perceive you
uh and then I think there's some
interesting books on psychology
um
like Contagious by Jonah Berger or even
Malcolm gladwell's book I mean we layer
a lot of human behavior and psychology
into the work that we do because it's
such a fundamental process of being able
to tap into audiences at scale yeah
those are some great recommendations and
of course you can always check out the
show notes for anything else uh along
those lines Brendan appreciates you so
much thanks for coming on the podcast
yeah thanks for having me it's a
pleasure to connect with you and
everybody that tuned in for this
wow wasn't that just amazing content I'm
ready to make a viral video how about
you uh well this episode is uh so power
pack that I recommend that you go back
and listen to it or if you've not yet
watched it over on YouTube I recommend
going and watching it too sometimes just
changing how you're receiving
information can really help to soak it
in more so if you listen to this go over
and watch it if you watch this go over
and listen to it as well well I want to
thank our think media Community for
supporting us here on this free show
it's been amazing to see this community
grow and to see all of your comments
flooding in on YouTube and on the rating
and review feature over on Apple podcast
today I want to shout out Rory and Sage
from our think media Community
congratulations on almost 1 000
subscribers guys they're at 864 at the
time of recording so I know you're
almost to that one thousand so I'm going
to forward congratulate you on that and
thank you for leaving this comment this
is so inspiring and motivating it's like
hang hanging out with other creators
love it well Rory and Sage we cannot
wait to hang out with you soon and thank
you so much for being a part of what
we're doing here on think media and over
on the podcast as well it's so
encouraging to read your comments and to
hear what your aha moments are from
different episodes like this and when we
bring on our guests you guys are so
honoring to them inside of the comments
and I know that that'll be the same for
this episode as well well again if
you've not yet signed up for our latest
free YouTube class that could be your
next step with us where we're going to
be breaking down the secrets to success
on YouTube what's working right now and
what's not and how you can get
breakthrough and make your first one
thousand dollars or get your first 1 000
subscribers on YouTube without a fancy
camera without years of editing
experience and without having to spend
50 hours a week on your YouTube channel
you can sign up for that free class over
at
thinkmasterclass.com or click on the
link down in the description box below
or in the show notes well thanks so much
for listening and we are so excited for
some of the future content we have for
you so stay locked here subscribed
wherever you're listening and we'll see
you in a future episode bye
[Music]